okay welcome back everyone to
lecture 12 of cs229 the
topics for today are bias variance
trade-off
model selection and cross validation and
regularization the three are
are kind of somewhat related to each
other
and i would say bias variance trade off
is probably
one of the most important topics that
you need to take away from this course
it it it's at the heart of machine
learning and
the concept that kind of is unique to
machine learning and distinguishes it
from
other fields right so a quick recap of
what we covered
uh over the last two classes so the last
two classes we covered neural networks
and deep learning
and the the main takeaways from the last
uh two classes was the neural networks
are basically composition
of simple building blocks where the
simple building blocks are
you know linear models that we've seen
in the past so
we we we take the output of one
one simple model and feed that as input
to
you know another simple model and so on
and the
crucial crucial thing while composing
the
composing them is having non-linearities
right and non-linearities are crucial
because if there were no non-linearities
then the entire network
could be represented as just a single
linear
single linear layer with one one matrix
and also neural networks and deep
learning they are
they are non-convex
and it's important that we initialize
the parameters randomly
whereas in the previous models that we
saw
the simpler models they were mostly
convex and
initialization did not matter but for
neural networks for example
initializing all your parameters to 0
will not work
because because of the symmetry
symmetry properties that we that we
discuss
and then the approach for training
neural networks was basically back
propagation
back propagation is just a fancy name
for the chain rule of multivariate
calculus
and what we saw was we
calculate the gradients of the final
loss with respect to every parameter
at all layers and in order to calculate
those
those gradients we use the multivariate
chain rule so the last layer was you
know a linear uh a linear model that
we've uh
you know very similar to glms and then
from from beyond the last layer as we
as we compute the gradients of
parameters from earlier layers
we see we saw that you we encounter a
chain of very simple jacobians they are
either
diagonal jacobians where each diagonal
entry is the
derivative of the non-linearity or it's
going to be the weight matrix so the
weight matrix itself will be
the jacobian right and
[Music]
we we construct the simple chain of
jacobians
until we arrive at the layer at which we
are calculating the gradient from
and then from from the
the branch that's specific to that layer
it was pretty
pretty straightforward calculus that
the notation was a little heavy but
it's it's pretty much you know there's
nothing nothing fancy going on there
it's just
simple simple uh gradients that we need
to
uh that we need to take and
to the end of of uh the last lecture
we saw this um or we just discussed
this theorem which is you know it's not
going to be in your in your
syllabus and we're not going to test you
on that theorem uh
but it's a it's a good kind of segue
into bias variance
because the universal approximation
theorem suggests that neural networks
can be
very expressive so it can represent any
possible
any any smooth and differentiable
function
on a given input range
and that that kind of ah brings us
into bias variance and asking the
question is that a good thing or a bad
thing you know having having expressive
models is that
is that good or is that bad so
that brings us to bias variance
any questions on neural networks or deep
learning before we
jump into uh bias variance any remaining
questions
okay so uh bias variant so in in your
homework one
in in the last question where we
we saw feature maps right so in feature
maps we ah
supposing we had a data data set
that looked like this
i'm plotting the same data set again
here
and here it's the same data set
right now if we fit a linear model
where the feature map is just a
polynomial of degree 1.
so k equals 1 we get
a straight line fit through the data
and if we try with k equals 2
whether the polynomial degree is 2
we get say a quadratic fit
similarly if we try with say k equals
20 right we would get a fit that might
look something like this
right now
we could have done something very
similar with say a classification
problem
right supposing the x is here
mark one class and o's mark
another
let's say this one x here and one over
here
supposing we had a data set like this
and say third i am just copying the same
data set
in three different places
here the ah x's mark one class and the
o's mark another class
now if we try to fit say a logistic
regression with
polynomial features say with k equals
one we would again get a straight line
fit
that tries to separate the two classes
if we try the logistic regression with k
equals two we would get a quadratic fit
and let us say we tried it with k equals
you know maybe
twenty right and we we would probably
get something that
could potentially look like this
right so um
loosely speaking we can call these
models
as being underfit
these models as overfit
so in machine learning we are given a
training set
but the the the error that we actually
care about
is not how well the model performs on
the given data set
but how well does the model perform in
general
on data that it has not seen before
you can call it loosely speaking the
test set but in general you know you you
call it
generalization error so generalization
error
generalization error is the error
or the loss or the cost that our model
incurs
when it is tested against possibly all
the infinite data
out there in the world from whose
distribution we got the training set
right and
in machine learning what we care about
is that our model needs to have a low
generalization error
but the the fundamental problem is that
what we have access to is just a finite
sample
from the from the you know uh the
the uh infinitely many possible examples
from the uh data distribution we have a
finite sample
from the data generating distribution
and we need using this finite sample we
need to build a model
that has good error rate or low error
when it is tested against all the
possible you know infinitely many
examples in our data distribution
so this
this concept of under fitting and over
fitting
is you can you can
think of underfitting and over fitting
as corresponding to
different uh components of the
generalization error
so loosely speaking generalization error
which means
taking the model that we obtained and
testing it against
an example that we have not seen before
and
when we test it against an example that
we've not seen it before there is going
to be some error
it's never going to be perfectly right
and that error
can be broken down into sub components
right so the
generalization error can be broken down
into two parts
a component called the bias and the
component
called the variance
and loosely speaking ah
bias is the component due to
what you can call as this is the
component
of generalization error i am going to
write it as g e
component of this generalized error
due to
expressivity handicap
and variance is the component
of generalization error
due to
finite sample of training set
right and the generalization error
that is incurred by this model
you expect it to be pretty high and the
generalization error incurred by this
model
is also expected to be pretty high but
they are high for
fundamentally very different reasons the
reason why
this model or these kinds of models
are expected to high have high
generalization error
is because they are linear models and
they are kind of have handicapped
and cannot capture this quadratic
relation
between between the x's and y's
similarly this model
is extremely expressive it can twist and
turn in wild ways
but it it it cannot generalize well
because it just it does not have enough
enough data to kind of
ah fit it fit it well rather
so it does extremely well on the given
training set
and in order to do well on the given
training set you know we are kind of
you know losing the big picture of
wanting to generalize well on unseen
data
and we do overly well on the training
side right and this is due to the fact
that we just don't have enough training
data
right if if we had a lot more number of
training data
then even though we had a higher
expressive model
it wouldn't have overfit on the data
like this right and
and we saw some amount of that in your
homework question as well
where if uh if we start with a small
data set where the number of examples is
very small then the higher order
polynomials
can over fit it by you know by forming
highly wiggly
hypothesis functions whereas if you had
a larger data set
even polynomials of higher degree can
you know do a pretty good job of
fitting the data
so loosely speaking bias is
the generalization error of a model
due to it being kind of handicapped in
its expressivity and
it just cannot uh even do a good job of
fitting the training set itself very
well
and variance is is
uh is due to the fact that your model
was highly expressive but it just did
not have enough data
for for it to um for it to generalize
well
right and these concepts um
these definitions are very loose these
are not standard definitions
but this is a good good kind of
intuition to have of of
what bias and variants are in fact
when we are using the
squared error as the loss function
in the setting of the squared error
and where the model is
and we assume that our data comes like
this y equals
f of x plus epsilon
where f is some function you know some
hypothesis right
um if if this is the true data
generating distribution
where the expectation of epsilon
is 0 and the variance of
epsilon is sigma square
right for in in this particular setting
the generalization error or the test
error
which is also the generalization error
is equal to you know the
expected
y minus f hat
x
square now lets lets analyze this for a
moment
so f hat let me suffix it with
n f hat n
is the is the model that we get by
fitting on n training examples
right and the n training examples were
obtained with this data generating
process
which means the n training examples
now are obtained with y i equals f of x
i plus
epsilon i right so the n training
examples from which the f hat was
ah obtained had noise embedded in them
right and therefore f hat n
is a random variable it is a random
function it is a random variable because
it is a function
over inputs that were random
right so f hat n is it accepts an input
as
x x is not random but the way f hat n
was constructed was using
n training examples and the n training
examples had noise in them
and therefore because the n training
f hat n is random
it is random but it accepts an input
which is deterministic
but the way f hat n itself was
constructed was is
it's a random variable and
what is this expression um what's this
expression calculating
it is calculating over here x and y
are appear from the test test set or
on on an example that the model has not
seen before
so on an example that the model has not
what is the prediction of our learned
model on the new input
and this is the error of of that model
with the new output right so this is
generalization error
and this expectation is
over the noise that is in the test
example
and noise in the training set right so
this is the expectation over all the
noise
uh noise uh variables both in the
training set and the test set
right so where expectation
is over
all epsilon
in training set
and test example
right and in the case of the squared
error we can see that
this can be with some
pretty simple
pretty simple algebra
we can show that this will be equal to
sigma square
plus expectation
of f
of x minus
f hat x
square plus
variance of
ok so over here f is the true function
that we do not have access to and f hat
f hat n
is the model that we obtained by
training on the finite
training training data and we can
decompose
this this error on a new test example
as into three components right this
component
is called irreducible error
and this component
is called the bias squared
bias squared and this component
is called the variance
right so what is happening here
so what what this is telling us is the
test error
of any model can be broken down into
into these three components now all of
these three components
are non negative because this is
this is a sigma square that is the
variance of the noise that is
non-negative
this is the bias squared so that is
and this is the variance of something
and that is non-negative so the test
error
or the expected test error can be broken
down into three components
now each of these
each of these three errors is a
is a fundamentally very different kind
of error compared to the other two
so irreducible error tells us that no
matter what kind of model we choose no
matter
how big training how big a training set
we start with
we can never do better than irreducible
error
and why is that that's because
fundamentally data is noisy
which means for the same given value of
x
for different examples y can be
different because of the noise term
which means at test time when we are
given a value of
x on which we need to make a prediction
the y value could be multiple
possible y values and there's just no
way we can we can
ah you know get the right get the right
prediction all the time because our
function f
is a deterministic function right and
that noise
is essentially what's captured in this
irreducible error right so irreducible
error is because
the data is noisy and for given value of
x there is no single right answer
right that's irreducible no matter what
kind of model you choose you choose a
neural network you choose a linear
regression choose
any fancy model you want you can never
do better than irreducible error
any questions on this yes
minus the actual
so the question was uh why is this
irreducible error because
by increasing k we we actually made it
go through all the points
so um and and the question is you know
is an epsilon zero in this case uh the
the uh answer to that is here we are
talking about
test error which means now we are
measuring how well
this model performs on a test point that
was not included in the training set
right so this is generalization error
which means we are measuring how well
the model performs on unseen data
right because doing well on the given
training set is an easy thing right
there you know it's
there is you know you don't need so much
of theory to do well on
just the given training set that you
have in fact if you're just given a
training set and
you want to do well on the training set
just memorize the training set
right the whole point of machine
learning is to start with a limited set
of training data
and still do well on generalization
error
right so generalization error is when
you are given a new
example that we have never seen before
the expected error can be
decomposed into an irreducible error
component
which is due to the fact that the data
is
noisy and then there are two more
components here
now what are these two components so the
first one
is the expectation of f x
minus f hat n x so what does this mean
there is a true underlying signal
that we do not have access to and the
true underlying signal
will be different from the prediction
made by our model
and in general what is the expectation
of this
of this ah of the difference between
of or the difference between the true
underlying signal and our
uh and the prediction that our model
makes in general
and if we take the expectation across
all the
all the possible different training sets
that we get and
expectation across the noise in the test
example
that gives us how how systematically
wrong are we
right what is the expected expected
difference between
the true signal and um
and and the predicted uh predicted value
and this is the square of that bias
and finally we have uh a third part
called the the variance of
f hat and x now what is what is the
meaning of the variance of
f hat and x it means if we were to
repeat this experiment with a new set of
n
examples right i do not mean repeat the
experiment of refitting on the same data
set
repeat this experiment by collecting a
new set of n
examples from the same data generating
distribution
f hat nx will be a different
the prediction on the test set will be a
different value right and now if we were
to keep repeating this process
over and over by collecting a new set of
an examples
and making a prediction on this uh test
set you know
and repeat again a new set of n examples
fit the model
make a prediction on uh the new test set
x
all these different predictions on the
new test set is going to have some
variance in it
right and this is the variance of the
prediction made on
a new test example when we are changing
the training set
to be a resample every time right
and this variance you can kind of see
was completely unrelated to what the
right answer for
f for the new test example was
right it's just how how sensitive to
noise we are
in the for the noise in the training set
and and that's captured by variance
this question
right so the question is uh because we
said variance is
is due to the limitation of having a
finite sample
test set now you can imagine um if your
population
has you know theoretically it has an
infinite number of
number of ah points infinite number of
examples
if you were to take the entire infinite
set of
training population and fit your model
and would you were to repeat it by
taking
the entire infinite set again and fit
your model
you always get the same model right
and the the variance that we get
from experiment to experiment where the
experiment includes collecting your end
training
examples the the the variance that you
get
from experiment experiment is due to the
fact that you're collecting a small
number of
finite examples if you were to collect
more number of
examples in each experiment then the
variance will come down
and we'll go a little bit deeper into
this shortly so coming back to your
question about the polynomial case
um in in our homework uh question five
what we saw was
with uh k equals 20
it was a pretty uh wiggly function now
if we were to repeat the k equals 20
case
with a data set of say 10 000 examples
then what you will see is that it it
will do you know fairly well it will fit
it fairly well
you re-sample a new set of what was the
number of said
twenty thousand or whatever you know ten
thousand examples you repeat it it will
be slightly different
right and you repeat it again you'll get
a new hypothesis which is again very
slightly different
and if you were to repeat this
experiment with a new number say you
know 10 million examples
then the the the variance from
experiment to experiment is going to
come down even further right the more
number of
examples you have they may be noisy
right you know you take 10 000 examples
each of those examples has noise in them
but the variance in the fitted model
from experiment to experiment is going
to come down the more number of examples
you have
we will come to that so the question is
you know is it uh is the relation linear
or quadratic we will come to that
shortly
right so this is in the context of
machine learning right
however um however i think
understanding bias and variance from a
more classical statistic
statistics setting is a little more
intuitive than understanding this
so so let us have a look at bias
variance
from a more classical statistics setting
because here we were focused on
prediction now how well does the model
or what does the model do when it is
presented with an x that is it has not
seen before
right so bias variance in a more
um
so lets assume there is a data
generating distribution
ah data x comma
y our pairs come from some
some distribution that's parameterized
by theta
right and what we do is from this
data generating distribution we collect
n
examples so each of this is a pair
x1 y1 until
xn yn
right we we sample x and y pairs from
the data generating distribution
and we sample n such insert pairs
and we run it through
a statistical model
right and by a statistical model ah
what what i mean is say the mle
estimator
you know it and what we get
out is a theta hat
right this is what we did for example in
in linear regression you know
if if we assume a linear relation
between x and y where
the theta captures the linear
coefficients
then this is just the normal equation
right but in general it is
some some statistical model if if this
is you know
x is x is some features and y is 0 1
then you know think of this as logistic
regression
and once you once you fit the model you
get the
the estimated parameters right
so now this is random
random because they were random samples
from our data generating distribution
right and this is
not random this is you know
deterministic
right and what happens when you feed a
random variable into a deterministic
function the output will be
random right so this is also random
and the weight is random ah we can we
can
visualize
so let us assume we have four different
statistical models right
so this is theta one this is
theta d theta d
and this is our parameter space you know
one so over here
we were looking at the data space right
so here this was x
and this was y and here this was
x1 and this was xd
right over here
we are in the parameter space right
that's that's uh
so it's a switch from that view theta
one theta d
theta one and theta d
now the the the data that we sampled
from came from some true distribution
let us call it theta star
right so theta star is some unknown
unknown constant that you know we do not
have access to
so let us you know assume theta star was
here
this is theta star
drawing it in the same position in all
the four
theta star this is theta
star yeah so so this this is basically
in the same position in all the four
ah four and let's let's assume we have
four different statistical models four
different estimators
of our parameter right and
we start an experiment we sample n
examples from this distribution
here we are assuming we have access to
you know
potentially sampling an infinite number
of points and assume sampling is cheap
right sample n examples where n is some
fixed number
run it through this statistical model
run it through each of the four models
so we have
so let us call this model a model b
model c
and model d and these four plots
correspond to a
b c and d
right and for a given sample of ah
n examples we get some estimate theta
hat right
so maybe you know
this was the estimate by a
and by b maybe this was the estimate
right and maybe from c this was the
estimate
and maybe from d maybe this was the
right so unfortunately i do not have
colored pens here but
maybe i will highlight this with
with a the true parameter
make it a little bigger as a block
because i do not have a different color
pen today
right and
and supposing we repeat the experiment
get a new set of n examples
fit it on the four different models and
because the new set of examples had
you know noise in them the estimated
theta is going to be different again
right and in this case let's say the new
estimate was here and
in this case the new estimate let's say
was was here
and over in this case let's say it was
here
in this case let us say it was here
right and then we repeat it
set of n run it fit it through four
different models
and plot the estimated values right so
let's say
it was here and let's say we keep
repeating it
so each each dot in these plots
corresponds to one experiment
right it is the output of one experiment
right
the number of dots is not the same as
the number of examples so the number of
each dot corresponds to one experiment
and
what we see is um we might get plots
like these
and what we would call what we see here
is
in in these in these two examples
the the variance of the expected
the variance of the estimator is pretty
small because they are they are
you know because they are pretty tightly
concentrated in one region
right whereas in these two cases the
variance is pretty large
right so you would call these two as
low variance
and these two as high variance
so a low variance estimator
and high variance estimator
right and similarly what we see is over
here
the distribution of theta hat so you can
you can think of
the dots that we obtained by you know
repeating this process as
samples from theta hat
the distribution of theta hat and that's
also called the sampling distribution
right so these each of these dots are
samples from the corresponding sampling
distributions
right and what we see is the sampling
distribution
is kind of centered on the true value
right so so the center of the sampling
distribution coincides with the true
value
in both the cases right so this is so
this is therefore called a low
bias estimator
and this the center of the sampling
distribution
is has moved away from the true
parameter so these you would call them
as high variance estimate
high bias estimators
so what we see is that bias and variance
are
are fundamentally different things right
having
one each having having low variance or
high variance
says nothing about whether the model has
high high bias or low bias
the way to think about high bias
is that the estimator has
has a fundamental systematic
error in estimating parameters in that
no matter how many times you you sample
different data sets and fit them
in this case they are you know
fundamentally kind of there is a
systematic bias
say in this case to be closer to zero
right and that has got nothing to do
with whether they have low variance or
high variance
similarly this model
has low variance these these these
models have low variance
which means no matter uh
no matter how much noise no matter the
noise that you get from you know
different uh training sets
the estimated value is somewhat you know
tightly
tightly grouped in some region right so
the the um it is less
swayed by the noise in the training set
that's one way to think of it
right in this case it may have a
systematic error in this case it may not
have a systematic error
but the these estimators are less swayed
by the noise in the training set
whereas these these two models are
pretty sw
they are sensitive to noise in in the
training set so
um depending on the specific
set of n examples you know the the
variance in the estimated values are
pretty large
any questions on this yes
yeah so i'll come to the trade off why
we call it a trade-off
what we what we then notice
is instead of n examples
let us say we collect a much larger set
of say
capital n you know which is
a much larger training cycle say
thousand times the size
right so x 1 y 1
all the way till x capital n
y capital n
if you increase your data set by a
large fraction by a large amount
what we observe is that in all the four
cases the variance will come down
right so
so with a large larger data set so this
is a
b c
d let's say these were the true values
yes so instead of small n number of
samples
we are repeating this this cycle of
experiments with
capital n examples in each experiment
what we see is that
the variance is going to come down
and in this case
right so this is with n examples and
this was with
small n examples
right so what we see is that
this is still has some bias left
but the variance has reduced much more
right and in this case
in all the cases the variance has come
down right but
the the these two still remain unbiased
these two still remain biased
and as n is increasing we see that
the bias is also kind of reducing as n
increased from here to here
and thats a pretty excuse me thats a
pretty common
phenomenon as well as you increase
as you increase n your your variance
will
almost always come down and
the bias also generally also
comes down so
so in a classical statistical setting
the
expected difference between theta hat so
the expectation of theta hat
is going to be the the center of your
sampling distribution
right so in
in in classical statistical setting the
expectation of theta hat minus theta
star is called the bias
if the the mean of the sampling
distribution is centered exactly at
theta star then the bias will be zero
right and the variance of theta hat is
called the variance
right and if
the
as n tends to infinity
so if the bias tends to zero as n tends
to infinity
then this is called a consistent
estimator
right so what does it mean as as
as the number of examples goes to uh
goes to infinity the variance you know
will generally come down
but also if the bias also goes to zero
as n tends to infinity
then it is called a consistent estimator
for example
[Music]
in in case of gaussians the maximum
likelihood estimator for
the variance
so theta sigma square hat
is equal to 1 over n
[Music]
y equals 1 to n x
i minus mu hat
i square so this is the
if you recall in case of the gaussians
the maximum likelihood estimator for
the variance parameter is this where mu
hat
is the estimated mean
this is a biased estimator this will
always systematically
underestimate the bias right but it's
also consistent which means as n tends
to infinity the bias vanishes
yes
yeah x i minus mu hat side
there's no either so
can you hear why
i won't go into details as to why it's
underestimating but uh
the the the general idea is that um
so sigma hat square
if it were to be one over n
equals one to n x i minus
mu so if this if you use the true mu
value then
it's an unbiased estimator but if you
use the estimated mu hat
then this is a biased estimator and
there are ways to you know
if you use n minus 1 there's a
correction you can apply to make it
unbiased
so this would be an unbiased estimator
so this is
unbiased this is biased
and this is again unbiased
and mle will use this one
if you if you perform mle on a gaussian
you will get this
but that is biased but it so happens
that even though it is biased as n tends
to infinity the bias vanishes
so it is still a consistent estimator
right if your bias vanishes as the
number of
examples goes to infinity then it is a
consistent yes question
this one
so this one is is it's generally called
the
unbiased estimator
where you apply this n you know ah n by
n minus 1 correction to get n minus 1
in place of n and that becomes
a bias but yeah so ah
a consistent estimator is one that
eliminates the bias as as the number of
example goes to infinity
and you can also see ah
so the limit as n tends to infinity
variance of theta hat
the rate at which this goes to zero
is the is also called the statistical
efficiency
right so how many examples does your
estimator need to be really confident of
the ah estimated ah estimated ah
parameter yes question um
this one yes so the mle is not always an
unbiased estimator
mle performs maximum likelihood so write
out the the likelihood
take the gradient set it equal to zero
or do gradient ascend and
you you end up with some parameter
estimate
so bias means that your answer is
consistently
wrong yes that's correct that's correct
yes
so the question is why isn't this the
maximum likelihood estimate
so maximum likelihood is a recipe or a
procedure for you to follow to construct
an estimator
right for in case of gaussian the
maximum likelihood estimator for mu
is unbiased but if you follow the same
maximum likelihood recipe and construct
an estimator for sigma it is going to be
biased
and there is no there is no
fundamental reason to tell when mle is
biased or unbiased sometimes it's biased
sometimes it's unbiased
with this one this one so there is
uh i can give you more details about
this if you post it on piazza but that's
not relevant to the discussion right now
uh but i'm happy to give you more
uh links to why this is unbiased
anyways that's that's the the whole
point of this was to
give you an example of a consistent
estimator
right as n tends to infinity they the
bias
vanishes right and the rate at which
the variance reduces as you increase
as you increase the number of examples
is called the statistical efficiency and
that could be
something like at the rate of one over n
or one over square root n in in
different scenarios it is
you get different rates right so
in the context in the context of
classical statistics
this is bias and variance because in
statistics we are
interested in estimating parameters
right and and our goal is to estimate
parameter and call it today
whereas in machine learning our goal was
to make predictions
on unseen examples right in machine
learning our goal is generalization
error
which means we are interested in
how well the error or how low the error
of our model is on unseen examples right
and and so
in in machine learning we are now
interested in this
in this in in the squared errors on
unseen examples
right and
this was a good visualization for the
statistical setting
where you where you have a true unknown
parameter and you know the estimator
gives you
uh you know a sampling distribution
either centered on it or
away from it either with the low
variance or high variance
similarly we can also kind of ah try to
visualize
uh this one to get a good sense of what
bias and variance
means in case of the squared error for a
prediction problem
so i'm just going to use the space right
on top here
maybe even push it up in case you wanna
refer to it in the meantime right
so to kind of understand understand this
so assume
we have a function so this is
x this is y let's say
this is f of x
right and the training data that we get
are basically samples of
some x calculate the f of x
and add some noise so this could be
similarly you know sample some other x
calculate f of x
and add some noise
so our training set might look like this
because that's our data generating
distribution now pick some x some x i
choose some x i evaluate f of x add some
noise
the noise is mean zero so the noise
could be positive or negative
and that's the observed y y i
right and now
say this was the ah the true
distribution so let me instead make this
a dotted line
because in general we do not have access
to
[Music]
y hat it is invisible to us we do not
know what
ah what
f of x truly is
right and we take these
this training set
and construct an estimator
say using maximum likelihood say you
know linear regression with
a polynomial set of features and let's
say
the the resulting model that is specific
to this training set
was
something like this so the dotted line
is the true f of x
and this line is f
hat n of x
right so
for a given x let us call as x star
test example right so for a given
test example
consider this vertical slice
the true distribution of
y is centered around the dotted line
so this is
this is the distribution of y equals
f of x plus
epsilon right and
if this were to have been in our
training set then
the corresponding y would have been
a sample from this distribution
right is that is that here if
if the distribution of y's
for this x star
is the corresponding y value that you
might observe right and if if
this this x star was in our training set
then the corresponding
y would have been a sample from this
distribution
right and that distribution has a
variance of sigma square
this has variance sigma square
right and that is the variance of
epsilon
right now let me
draw this part a little bigger over here
so
i'm just going to focus on
this is f of x right
and
it has a distribution for
y and we are interested in
x star
right now if we take n examples
from our training set and construct an
estimator
that estimator say estimator one for
from experiment one
might go like
this so
this is from experiment one
we collect another set of an examples
fit our model from those n examples and
plot it
that might look like i don't know this
this is experiment two
right what were we in in this in this
example
each experiment resulted in a dot right
in this in this setting each experiment
results in the corresponding
hypothesis that looks like that and so
on so as you keep repeating n
we will get different hypotheses
and what this is measuring is that the
expected difference between
the point where the dotted line so this
this point over here
is f of x
and the points where the different
hypothesis are crossing this line
each one of them are samples
from f hat
n of x
this looks a little messy because
unfortunately i do not have different
colors but
let me repeat what is what is happening
here so this this vertical line
is like the slice that's of interest to
us because we are measuring the
what what's happening at when we predict
that x star
the dotted line that passes through it
is the
the true function that we do not have
access to which is why it is a dotted
line
and this distribution
represents the y values that
from which we you know from which
observations are made
for the for the specific
x star for example y in the in the test
error
would be a sample from from the from the
y corresponding y distribution or y
given x distribution
and because we are using different
number of
training examples or different sets of
training examples to fit our model
we get different hypotheses
that are kind of near to the true dotted
line
so this to the to the true f of x right
and these points
where the different hypotheses cross the
vertical line
are the different values of f hat n of x
does that make sense yes question so
you're saying that
you don't have access to the dotted line
you usually use the average prediction
to estimate it because
we don't know so so the question is how
do we know how do we calculate the
dotted line
we don't know so in this expression um
that's a very good question
so the test error the expected test
error
can be decomposed like this and this is
a mathematical expression
right we cannot compute these components
right you in
you know you you you mentally you kind
of
break it down into these sub components
but it's very hard to
actually compute the two different
components because
we do not know what f of x is exactly
right and if we knew what f of x is then
we could compute it but then why even do
machine learning because we already have
access to f of x
we want to measure our equipment or you
want to measure some
the effect of different circumstances
then we could always
know the truth and as a result use that
to measure the effect right
i'm just saying that there is some use
to it but generally speaking we don't
have access to that we don't have yes
the you know we don't know what f of x
is that's that's the uh uh
fundamental assumption yes question
based on the same question if you want
to
like systematically know uh after
repeating many experiments
whether you are under conducting or
overproductive can you like do
let's say 1000 examples like thousand
different predictions uh
fitting and then see on average if you
take the average parameter
and on from that average parameter this
certain parameter is
less than or more than use that average
of different
thousand experiments as the true
estimate
so the the question is can we repeat the
repeat the experiment multiple times
to guess whether we are systematically
underestimating or overestimating
from experimentally it's very hard to to
calculate because we don't have access
to
the true y distribution if we had access
to the true y distribution if we could
take an infinite number of samples from
the true y given x
then we could do such a comparison but
in in general it's it's uh hard to do
anyway so moving on so the the way to
think of
um the think of this test error
is that let's say we end up with this
hypothesis
and our prediction is over here right
and let's say the test example was also
sampled
from this y distribution say maybe we
this value right so this square error so
the expectation
of the square of this distance can be
broken down
into the variance of of
the y y given x distribution itself plus
the systematic bias you know uh whether
our distribution of f n is it going to
systematically be
below f star below the dotted line or is
it going to be above the dotted line
the square of that plus the variance of
f
f hat and x which means in general
do the the different um how how spread
apart
are the different hypotheses the value
of the hypothesis at that line
right it's a little hard to visualize
because you know i'm using black color
everywhere but
uh but maybe you can you can sit down
and kind of
write it out yourself on your own book
and um and understand this
right so the the square error
so the squared error is the only error
that allows for such a clean
decomposition
for other errors for example ah the
logistic regression loss
there is no well accepted you know
decomposition in this way but there are
a few papers which kind of
unify this um to to other kind of losses
as well and and yeah um i can share
those links if anybody's interested
but the the idea here is that squared
error
can be decomposed into these parts and
you can think of
this decomposition visually like this
unfortunately this figure is a mess and
also kind of see the similarities with
the more classical statistical setting
where the visualization is much easier
what what's happening over here in case
of prediction
is actually very similar to what's
happening over here
if you were to kind of put them all in
one one single axis
you know maybe maybe you can you know do
that on your own
as an exercise right
so that's that's bias various
decomposition
the general take away from bias various
variance decomposition is that
under fitting
roughly means you have high bias
right over fitting
you know approximately means you have
high variance
and these are approximate terms so you
know you can have models that are
that have high bias and high variance
which means
your model can simultaneously be under
fitting and overfitting at the same time
right it could mean that your model has
fit to the noise of your data but just
hasn't fit to the signal at all so your
model could theoretically
have be under fitting and overfitting at
the same time
right and and this is this is just a
a heuristic or a rule of thumb to talk
about how
you know how our model is is performing
this question
so overfitting if it's fitting and under
fitting at the same time don't you call
it just over fitting um
no no if it's under fitting and over
fitting at the same time one example
could be
let's say your
so in in the case 20 case it is over
fitting and not under fitting
right so if you have data that is
pretty noisy right you could have you
know theoretically you could have a
model
that that might give you a hypothesis
and if you take a different sample the
hypothesis might look very different
and it still doesn't fit your data at
all it's just capturing the noise but
maybe hasn't captured the signal so it
sways a lot depending on
the sample that you get but still
doesn't go through it so that
is you know it is kind of over fitting
and under fitting at the same time
but these are just heuristics right so
what what you
what you want to do in general now
what what we've discussed so far is is
is mostly for you to build a mental
model of what's going
on under the covers but what you
actually do
in practice the actions that you take is
what you are going to discuss next and
that is called cross validation
so
so remember our goal
is to do well
on generalization
realization error
right of course in in in cases when the
generalization
error is measured as as say the
squared loss or the squared error we can
decompose it into
um into bias and variance but in general
what we care about
is that we just want to have low
generalization error
right and the irreducible error is like
a lower bound on how low
the generalization error can be
but your your um
but we we we still want to do you know
as as well as we can
and the the idea of
measuring how well we are doing on
generalization error
so the the idea behind how we do it is
something very simple we call it cross
validation
what that means is when you are given a
data set we do not use
our complete data set to fit our model
instead what we do
is split it
into a training set
a dev set and a test set right so split
it
generally into three parts into
train call it validation
or dev set they are synonymous and a
test set
and historically there have been um
you know rule of thumbs that you know
this needs to be you know
70 percent and 20 percent
ten percent or you know some people do
it
sixty percent twenty percent twenty
percent
or eighty percent ten percent ten
there is no single right answer right
and you split it
into three different uh three different
uh um splits
and you fit your model on only the
training set
and you you uh the so for
when you when you do maximum likelihood
you're doing it only on on the training
set which means you're you know doing it
on some fraction of the data
and then you need to you need to make a
decision of whether you want to
increase your feature map size reduce
your feature map size should you use
logistic regression versus
you know svms do you want to use neural
networks there are all these decisions
that you need to make
right and broadly speaking we're going
to call them hyper parameters
do you want to increase the number of
layers or do you want to add
regularization we're going to talk about
regularization next
right all these decisions we call them
hyper parameters
and the way you go about deciding on
what type of parameters you want
is by not measuring how well your model
is doing on the training set
but use the fitted model and make
predictions on the validation or dev set
and see how well your model is
performing in those
predictions right you would expect
your training your training error to be
over optimistic because the objective is
to minimize the training error so
you know there is there is a systematic
bias to
your that your training error will be
lower than the generalization error
so to get a better estimate of how well
we are doing on our
on our goal our goal which again is to
do well on generalization error
is to measure measure it on you know
have have a hold out set
you know pretend it is you know unseen
examples that you are
encountering in in production and see
how well the model does on
on those examples and
it is common practice to repeat
uh this cycle multiple number of times
so you would you
you take the training center training uh
data that you have
start with some model say logistic
regression
see how well it did on your validation
set you know
maybe you're happy maybe or not very
likely you will not be happy the first
time
and say you you go about increasing your
feature map size right you started with
k equal to 1
you set it to k equal to 10 right
and you fit your model again and
measure the performance on the
validation set with the new model which
has you know a higher
feature map and if it has over fit your
validation error is going to go up
even though your training error came
down your validation error is going to
go up if it has overfit
right and you realize that you overfit
and you you know take back your decision
of going with k equals
10 and maybe try k equals 2 or maybe k
equals 5 and so on and the decision
could be
things like the size of your feature map
it could be things like
use neural networks versus logistic
regression it could be
you know the number of layers in a
neural network so no matter
what your hyper parameter decision is
the process of cycling between the train
set
and the validation set is essential
right
and this is this is one of those things
that is so pervasive
and so universal for all of machine
learning
that it is something you should you
should spend some time thinking about
and and it's it's you know always good
practice to follow
and that that process of having
a hold out cross validation set against
which you are
measuring the quality of your hyper
parameter tuning
is so universal that it works for any
kind of hyper parameter in general
right so it could be it could be
something as
simple as you know what is the
regularization parameter
versus you know choice of different
algorithms
all those all those kind of choices come
under the same umbrella
of being evaluated using this
validation approach right now why do we
have this test set
right you know we we had this hold out
validation set but why do we still have
this test set
the reason is because just in the same
way how
the training set gave us an over
optimistic estimate
of our models performance
after repeatedly
performing hyper parameter tuning to do
well
to do better on the validation set we
also kind of over fit on our validation
set as well
right by repeating this cycle we are
over fitting
on the validation set more and more even
though we do not explicitly minimize our
training loss on this
right one way to think about it is the
when you obtain a data set for the first
time before you evaluate your model or
fit your model on it think of it as
fresh
and every time you fit a model and look
at its
outcome or every time you
val use it as a validation set and look
at the outcome
mentally you need to think of that data
set as rotting every time you look at it
it rots a little bit
right and the more number of times you
you run your model
on that data set or you train your data
set on that model and
look at the outcome that data set is
rotting
right and
to as a way to kind of counter that
rot effect you have this test set
that you always keep away all the way
until the very end
right you may be going through the cycle
you know
a lot of number of times but all this
while you need to keep your test set
away
and just not even look at your test set
right in the end once you're satisfied
with your performance
you know in order to get a realistic
expectation of your generalization error
only for that purpose all the way all at
the very end
you measure your the performance of the
model in the test set and that
gives you you know a rough approximate
of how well it is going to do in in
generalization error
right so the purpose of the training set
and the validation
so the purpose of the training set is to
do well on training set
slash minimize loss
the purpose of the cross validation set
is to do well
for generalization error do well
in generalization error
right the purpose of the test set which
strictly speaking you need to evaluate
your test set
only once all the way at the end
and never again is to give you
get an estimate
on
generalization error
right
and in practice because going through
the cycle
you know rocks your validation set and
over time if you if you repeat this this
cycle too many times
your validation set is no longer you
know
a good sample of your of of
generalization performance
it is sometimes quite common to have
multiple levels of validation sets
right you can have multiple validation
sets where
you know once you kind of repeat the
cycle with one validation set and
you feel that you kind of you know over
fit
on this validation set through your
hyper parameters it's quite common to
discard that validation set and move on
to the next validation set
right and that's that's common too and
you want to keep your test set
all the way to the very end and and the
purpose of the test set
is to give you an estimate of how well
your generalization error
will be off at the end of the cycle yes
question
is that um
is there a number of end times you know
past that
it is highly likely that we have um
overfitted validation set
yeah so the question is how do we know
that we overfit on our
validation set one um
there is there is no there is no clear
answer to know how whether we overfit on
our validation set or not um
the the one way you can ha
you know check whether you overfit on
your validation set is to
um is to have yet another validation set
and and you know you're making your
decisions against one validation set
but you could just measure the gap
between the model performance on
the validation set with which you're
making decisions versus some other
validation set
which you're using only for the purpose
of detecting whether you fit on
the first validation set
yeah so in general in general there is
um when when does the cycle end there is
no well-defined answer for that um and
and uh it it is something that you you
use your judgment to say you you know
you've done your best
this question
and then what should we do yeah that's a
very good question
you know we go through all of this
finally we you know measure our test set
um what do we do you know the
performance is really bad
and um strictly speaking
you know you need to use your test set
only for the purpose of just getting an
estimate of how well you're going to do
but you know it's a it's a good question
what do you do in if you know if you
don't do well on your test set and
the um you know in real life
you know if you're trying to take
something into production you still want
to do something about it
and for those purposes it's always good
to have
you know yet another tester that you you
you haven't looked at
otherwise you can always go through this
and and and kind of you know
check your test set uh tested
performance again
but in a way you're now starting to rot
your test set now
yeah and and and that's like a
fundamental paradox for which there's no
right answer yes question
if you have a very small amount of data
can you do this where you do 80
then you fit like you do
cross-validation find your optimized
uh structure and everything then you get
a test error
let's say it's five percent you're
satisfied with it take the entire set
like
including the hundred percent fit it
through the model
using the same architecture and then use
those final parameters
to take advantage of the entire thing
yeah so the question is
um can we fit the model on on
the uh 80 or some percent go through the
cycle
measure it on the test set now we are
happy with everything now
stick to the same set of hyper
parameters that you
that you used and refit the model on the
full
full training set you can do that um
if your data set is is reasonably large
then you know that
that might work well but then sometimes
if your model
is pretty sensitive to small variations
in your
training data then you may want to just
hold on to the model that you have
which happens to be you know working
reasonably well rather than
you know risking it and fitting it on
the full date data set you know
especially if you're
if your model is kind of sensitive to
noise in the data set
but you know you you can certainly do
that in most cases
in in practice people generally do not
do that
you you know
well let me take that back it depends on
how big your data set is
right if your data set is reasonably
large say you have a million examples
and you have some you know tested that
you've kept apart
and you repeat this uh let's say you
kept away you know a thousand examples
uh
in your test set and you repeat it then
there's not much value when you already
you know you have like 999 000 um then
you know there's little value in adding
another thousand to refit it
but if you're in a smaller regime where
let's say you have a hundred example and
you've kept away twenty then it might be
worth
what doing it good question right
so this is this is ah this kind of
cross validation is also called is
called holdout cross validation
where you take a fixed validation and
test set
and keep it away and
put your model only on the training side
so this called hold out cross validation
there is another kind of cross
validation technique
called k fold cross validation
and this is more common when you have
small data sets
so the idea behind k fault cross
validation
is to take your draining set
right so x one y one
till x n
y n right and
split it into k folds
in this case k is one two three four
right and what you do is
once you split it into k folds you fit
k different models where for each model
you take one of the folds as the
validation set
and use the remaining force aggregate
the remaining force as your training set
right so for model one
fold one is the validation set
and fold two to n
is the test set is the training set
there is no you can you can also have a
separate test set that you don't
touch at all but it's quite common to
use the full training set to perform
k-fold cross-validation right and for
model two
fold two is the validation set
and fold one comma
three to n is training set
right so one model at a time pick a fold
make that your validation set
use the remaining folds as your training
set right
and using the corresponding model
make predictions on the corresponding
validation set
so from model one
model one we use um
for model one we this is the training
set right
using the training set make predictions
on it and get your predictions here
y hat from model one
right and similarly for fold two
take model two model two was trained on
these go into model 2
right and using model 2 make predictions
y hat from
right and similarly for each model make
the prediction
into the corresponding fold and you're
going to get your full set of
predictions
of y hats and your full true label
wise and using these two you can measure
you know you may have some kind of some
kind of
evaluation metrics such as you know
maybe accuracy
maybe squared error maybe area under the
rfc curve
and you can use these you know the the
true labels and the predictions
for the full data set and see how well
your model is doing next question
right so for model model two makes
prediction on fold two
but model two's training set is fold one
fold three and
all the way clear right everything
except the corresponding fault
is part of the training side right and
this is called k fold cross validation
and this is more commonly done when your
mod
your model is not very computationally
expensive and your data is not very big
and in fact you can even take this to
the limit
where k equals number of examples right
so you have one model for example for
which that example becomes the
validation example and all the rest of
the examples are part of the training
set for that model
and that's also called leave one out
cross validation
cross validation where k equals
n next question
in this case there's no distinction
between validation
yeah so the question is is there a a
difference between validation set and
test set and you can still have a
separate test set that is not part of
this
k fold process you can still have a
test set under but most
most of the times when you do k-fold
cross validation or leave one out cross
validation
you're doing it because your data set is
really small let's say you have just 20
examples
so let's say you're you have a data set
of some very rare disease
you know for which the number of
patients is just a very small fraction
and you want to build a model in that
in those cases doing this would be a bad
idea because you know
you have only 20 examples you don't want
to lose let's say four of those 20
just for the purpose of cross validation
uh and in those cases you do leave one
out or or
k-fold cross-validation because you know
you want to kind of
use your all the data that you have to
build a model in some way and not
leave some expensive data in those cases
you generally would not have a separate
test set and um you would just uh at
and you you do cross validation like
this
and then you could either just use the
ensemble of all the k models
and average their predictions at test
time or you can
use this use this procedure only for the
purpose of
deciding your hyper parameters and take
those hyper parameters and just refit
using the entire data set
right and both both of those are are
commonly done
yeah in that case you you can think of
your validation error and test error to
be the same
though this process you know um yeah
this this cycle does not fit well with
this
procedure yeah
right any any questions on this before
we move on to regularization
all right
this question
so is there you know um
is there a good reason not to sample
from your
training set itself
so there is there is a process where you
take your data set and you know sample
from it
and fit a model and you know do it again
and
that's called bootstrap however
bootstrap is generally used
for um bootstrap is is generally used to
obtain
uh what what we saw previously as the
sampling distribution
for getting an um a distribution over
your parameters
right and it's not commonly used
in machine learning where the goal is to
do prediction on unseen examples
uh it's it's more of a technique to get
uncertainty estimates or confidence
intervals on
your model parameters and that's more
commonly used in in
in more classical statistics settings
where you want to get confidence
intervals on your parameters
it doesn't it doesn't help us a lot
in terms of getting you know
generalization error
estimates
all right regularization
so first let's ah we're going to have a
quick
quick motivation for regularization and
and in in this lecture we will cover
regularization from a bayesian
perspective
so if you remember in in the case of
k equals 20 in linear regression right
x and y where k was the degree of
polynomials
right we got a hypo this is function
that was very wiggly
right and
if you look at the coefficients of
the of the resulting theta vector
that corresponds to this very wiggly
hypothesis
you will notice that in order to get
these very sharp
wiggles the theta the
the magnitude of theta high theta i
should be large
right if all your theta i values are
small
then the resulting hypothesis even for k
equals 20 will be something which is
much smoother
right so it is these large values of
theta
that makes for these highly wiggly
turns in in the hypothesis function and
the general intuition is that
um having something so wiggly is bad
you know that's the general intuition
because it's very unlikely that
uh you know x's that are that are
so nearby would have very you know would
have y
values that are differing so much it's
more likely that you're going to have
models where
the hypothesis is much smoother where
nearby values of x have
nearby values of y and
using this intuition we want to come up
with ways
in which the our estimator
will output small values of theta we
still want to have
the flexibility of you know k equals 20
and have
have uh the ability to fit our data
if necessary but at the same time we
also want to keep the
magnitude of each of the theta i to also
be kind of as small as possible because
that encourages
smoother hypotheses right so the
[Music]
the ah the technique of
let's not call it keeping of
encouraging
small values of theta
is you know think of it as
regularization
now how can we kind of um
not let the noise in the data sway our
fit hypothesis
to this extent and and yet
uh you know still be flexible to some
degree
but encourage smoothness in the
resulting hypothesis that's the goal of
regularization
and the goal of regularization
is almost actually you know stated in in
in the statement itself that we want
small values of theta right this
question
why would you want to reduce
or just the number of dimensions
so the in in regularization we reduce
the the values of taken on by each
component so regularization
um yeah so it we want to make the the
values of of theta small
should that solve that problem
that will be solved by making the
dimensions of theta itself smaller right
that's a cubic and that's a
yeah so so we could so the question is
um
we can solve this by reducing
the number of thetas that we have right
and
you know so what why are we trying to
reduce the value
the magnitude of theta rather than just
reducing the dimensionality of theta
right and
that's that's a valid approach too and
we'll see that one of the regularization
techniques
you know achieves that goal um so so
so the intuition there is if if your
theta i equals zero for some i then you
implicitly kind of reduce the number of
thetas and and we
we're going to cover all these uh
shortly right so in general
the the intuition is that smaller values
of theta i
so this is bad
we want theta ice to be
to be small so ah one way to do it is to
is to penalize large values of theta
right and what that means is ah in case
of linear regression if our cost
function
g of theta it was
i equals one to n
y i minus h theta
of x i square
so this was standard linear regression
where h theta of x was
it was just theta transpose x right
so we take this standard loss of linear
regression
and kind of add on this
extra constraint by penalizing
by penalizing the norm of the theta
vector
the idea here is that this extra term
in the loss function will penalize
the model for selecting theta i's that
are very large
and therefore give us very wiggly
hypotheses
right and
this seems um i and and what so what is
the value of of of
lambda in this case so lambda is some
coefficient
or weighting factor of how much
we care about the original objective
versus how much we care about having
small theta
so if lambda is very big
then the model will focus more on
making the values of theta small and
might not even fit
our fit the data at all if
lambda is 0 then the model will just
fit our data as the original objective
without any regularization
right so lambda acts as this this
relative weighing factor between the
original data fitting objective and the
regularization objective
and the way we go about you know tuning
the value of lambda is through
cross validation exactly so use cross
validation
to figure out what lambda value
works well for on your validation set
right and and refit the model so this
this is
loosely speaking this is a
regularization a few
things to um
a few things to observe is that the norm
that we used here was the two norm
you could also use
the one norm right and the one norm is
basically
ah so this is basically lambda times
i equals one to d theta i
it's just the sum of the absolute values
nice question
so the question is why not learn lambda
using mle
and the so so by definition mle
will
will give you a 0 lambda i think
wouldn't it because our goal is to
minimize this loss this is always
non-negative so the way to
minimize this is to just set lambda to
0. so mle will give you lambda equals 0.
this question sorry it's still not clear
to me why
why why that is the correct goal to have
to
minimize the norm of theta how how is
that
so am i correct to say that we want to
minimize the norm of theta because we
want to
not over reducing theta reduces
yeah so the question is why why does
reducing the norm of theta
uh help um help or fight over fitting
so the norm of the theta if you remember
um
this is equal to sum over i equals 1 to
d theta i square
right so the the idea that if you want
to have small values of theta and you
want
you know all your values of theta to be
small you know sum over the squared
values
and now that's that's the um
that's the general idea right so you
know if if all your thetas are are
reasonably
small then you get a a smoother function
so you know penalize
penalize those values right so
um however this seems a little arbitrary
uh i mean
you know it seems a little hacky we just
we knew we used our intuition to
that large values of theta kind of cause
over fitting so let's directly penalize
it which which seems kind of
a little hacky but however
regularization has a very
very nice bayesian interpretation right
if you remember
if you remember in the in the bayesian
setting we had theta
come from some prior distribution
right and your data i'm just going to
call it s for both x and y's
so s given theta is something which is
called the likelihood
and we construct the posterior
is called the posterior
right in in the bayesian setting all we
did was construct the posterior
distribution
so p of theta given s
is equal to p of s
even theta times p of theta
over p of s
right and this gives us a full
distribution over theta
and we use this distribution
into test time to construct the
posterior predictor distribution
of you know for constructing p of
y star given x star
comma x y was equal to
expectation of theta let's call it
theta hat sampled from p of theta given
s of p of y
given y star given
x star times p
theta hat right so we constructed the
posterior predictive distribution from
from the posterior distribution
however only in simple models
is this integral tractable in most cases
this inter
this integral is not tractable it's very
hard to perform this integration to
construct
a posterior predictive distribution let
alone the posterior predict
distribution it's very hard to construct
even the posterior distribution of the
parameters itself
in simple models it's possible we saw
that in bayesian linear regression it's
possible
but in a lot of other models
constructing this posterior is extremely
hard
so what's done in practice
is and this is something that you have
on ps2 as well
is something that's called map
or
maximum a posteriori
parameter
estimate right so
what we instead do is take our posterior
distribution
right this is now a distribution over
your parameters
it is not a single point estimate it is
a full distribution over all the
infinitely many possible parameters
and out of this we extract just one
parameter setting called map
which is the arcmax so theta hat
map is
the arc max of theta of from the
posterior
what is the arc max of
so if you have a distribution over
this theta this is p of theta given s
what we want is to find a point
which maximizes p of theta given s
okay so we want this to be our theta hat
map so the map estimate
is the mode of the posterior
distribution
right the value of the parameter that
has the highest density or the
probability
in the posterior distribution and
and now once we once we obtain this
we are going to switch back to the
frequent test setting and make our
prediction
using h theta
at m a p on unseen examples x star
right so this is called map estimation
and what we are going to see now is that
regularization is essentially
doing map estimation with particular
choices
for the prior distribution right well
let us let see what what exactly we mean
by that
so what we were doing before was not
taking the mean of this distribution we
were
holding on to the full distribution to
construct
the posterior predictive distribution
right we were holding on to the full
distribution
to construct the the posterior
predictive distribution
right now we are not holding on to the
full distribution we are going to just
pick one value
of theta and switch back to the
frequency setting
of using that as the estimated value
this question
it is very similar to mle and that's
what we're going to see and that's what
you're going to show in your homework as
well it's it's it's
so what we want to do is theta hat
equals r max
i'm actually probably doing some of your
homework here for you so
now pay attention p of
theta given s right and
this is equal to
arg max of p of s given theta
times p of theta over
p of s right but p of s has no theta
uh term in it so this is just
arg max p of s given theta
times p of theta and
you can apply the log here because log
is monotonically increasing
and you get
r max theta log
p of s given theta plus
log v of theta
right so this is the map estimate and
now
what we are seeing here is that we are
trying to find a value of theta
that satisfies this times this
right its trying to balance out two
different competing weights
if p of theta is gaussian
normal with some covariance or sigma
square
then it is going to be
your original likelihood term so this is
your likelihood
and this in case of
p of theta to be gaussian as we have
seen before
will turn out to be
some constant times lambda square
remember the log likelihood of a
gaussian
exp minus half
if it's mean 0 then it's just the square
over here
and you take the log of this it's going
to cancel out everything
except the square and that's exactly
what you see here right so
having a gaussian prior on your
parameters
and performing m ap estimation
is effectively the same as adding a reg
a squared
an l2 regularization on your
on your on your mle estimate so this
could be in case of regression this is
the square loss
right and there is also ah you can you
know
do a quick visualization of this so if
this is
your theta and this is 0
then your prior
is some distribution that's so this is
prior
and over here let us say this is your
let let's call this likelihood
right and this is your mle estimate
so mle maximizes the likelihood
right so assume this just peaked over
here
and instead what you're trying to
maximize is the product of these two
right the the prior times the likelihood
and how how does the product of two
functions look right
so if either one of them is very close
to zero then the product is zero
right so over here the prior is
close to zero so the product will be
zero
over here the likelihood is zero so the
product is zero
so instead what we get is
so this is
prior times
likelihood right is the prior times
likelihood because
in any place where either of the prior
or the likelihood is zero the product
will be very close to zero
so only in in the region where both of
them are kind of non-zero that's where
the maximum
will be observed and map estimation
will get us this one here right so theta
hat
map right so what we see is that
m ap so there is this kind of um
there is this conflicting forces between
the prior
trying to pull the parameter estimate
close to zero
and mle trying to estimate you know pull
it towards
what the data tells us the the estimate
is
and map is kind of trying to
you know find the right balance between
the prior and the likelihood
and it's going to therefore shrink your
mle
close to zero
right yes question statistics
when you invasion statistics when you
choose a prior for your parameters
you choose the family and the parameters
so the the initial belief ah
is basically captured in the parameters
of your theta uh
the theta prior so if you have a strong
belief that
your parameters are close to zero then
you will assign a very small variance
which means your prior is
peaked and if your prior is peaked at
zero then this pull is even stronger and
your map will be even closer to zero
and sometimes it's common to use
something what's called as a flat prior
which means your prior is just flat
which means your likelihood multiplied
by the prior is going to
hold the same shape so that's when you
use something that's called a flat prior
where you don't want to do
anything at all but in that case you
know you don't have
the regularization interpretation for
the regularization interpretation
your prior needs to be a gaussian and
this lambda is is going to you know
involve terms
of the you know sigma square and and few
other things which you do in your
homework but the general idea is this
you know
um you know this this acts as a
regularization term
because of the squared error that comes
out here
yeah so how confident we are depends on
what kind of uh
variance we assign to the prior all
right um
uh if there are any other questions feel
free to walk up to walk up here and i
can answer that and that's all for today
thanks